when the Kardashian crew gets together
for a family photo it is a freaking mood
things might be tense between Kim and
Kourtney on the current season of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians let's
show her if she doesn't want to show up
she doesn't want to work she has too
many boundaries she's out but don't
worry guys Kim just posted a family shot
from their trip to Japan so things must
be okay right
yeah so anyway Kim hit up Instagram on
Wednesday night to share this pic with
her sister Kourtney her hubby Kanye West
some friends and almost all of their
kids posing it up on a jungle gym she
captioned the epic family photo so many
moods hashtag Tokyo really no but
seriously
so many moves but the mood that is most
hashtag relatable courts youngest son
rain who has his head thrown back mouth
wide open and is sobbing now that that
is a mood court explain the tears in the
comments writing that someone was
standing on his fingers from the looks
of it it's either his cousin north or
one of his siblings Mason or Penelope
anyway the only cutie missing from the
shot was Kim and Kanye's youngest son
saw West is just adorable and hey I just
want to give Kim and Kourt props because
while they may not have nailed to this
pic it's got to be hard wrangling all
those kiddos what's her name
[Music]
only me yeah remember in May when court
surprised her mom Kris Jenner on Ellen
by bringing six of her ten grandkids to
the show good Jesus spoiler hey rainy HL
yeah that was wild
that was nutty and of course by now we
all know the drama that went down in
2018 when Kim tried to get the whole
family in one room to take their annual
Kardashian Christmas card photo here and
go no one was there you shoot I'm
planning it we don't want you in the
shoot she's the least exciting to look
at
so she can be up well that wasn't very
Christmassy it's really important to me
that our family does a Christmas card
this year because last year we didn't do
one and it's been a tradition for so
long I just have a lot going on right
now
here's hoping the family got it together
for a 20-19 Christmas card of course you
can count on ET to spill all the
Kardashian tea so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Holly Stephens see you soon
[Music]